first and foremost how does it feel to
be holding those
grammys um it feels amazing um
i couldn't believe i was here when i got
here and i definitely can't believe i'm
leaving here with
3ds did you have any idea beyonce was
sitting down there
literally i looked and i was like is
that beyonce that's beyonce
so every time i see beyonce i get
excited like i've never seen her before
what how cool was that that she was
there to have that moment with you
it was just such an epic moment um
beyonce is a treasure to everybody in
houston
pretty sure to everybody in the world
but specifically from where we're from
we just live
absolutely love beyonce and to have her
like just
seal the deal for me like it's like a
pat on the back like i am proud of you
girl i'm like
thank you and she set a record tonight
how important was that too
it's very important uh as just a black
woman entertainer
uh black women in general um we're here
we're here to stay we're here to take
over we've been doing that but
like just shout out to beyonce for
making her story tonight
all right one other thing that
performance tonight y'all hung it you
let it all
out there i did yesterday i feel like i
really wanted it to be like black
hollywood
um i had to have my female tappers they
were great
um my men were out there they were
amazing we spent
so many weeks i feel like it was a whole
month preparing for this performance and
to see it all come together i'm so happy
um where are you partying tonight where
are you how are you gonna celebrate um
we're just gonna do a whole lot of hot
girl tonight
that's perfect
you